voici jan voss interview pinceau sur le
parcours d'un enfant de hambourg en six
minutes est illustrée lors jan voss
bonsoir en tutu et soir tu es née à
hambourg qui est venu s'installer en
france à paris en 1960 et à cette époque
tu faisais encore de la figuration
narrative
et
surtout des dessins rendent en ans avec
non
tél
inspiré par les bandes dessinées ou par
des séquences des cinémas par des
graffitis de murs ou des choses comme ça
et dans les 70 c'est devenu plus
abstrait déjà et oui petit à petit cette
figuration griffonné 10 ans est devenu
plus précise d'abord et puis
petit à petit a complètement basculé
devenu un espèce de carreaux de pièces
détachées dans les 80 ces partis
carrément sur les reliefs et presque
vers les directement vers la sculpture
précédant la révolution sévère famille
en utilisent tous c'est à dire il ya des
morceaux de bois il ya des morceaux de
papier pliée il ya des dégoûts de
cageots il ya des bouts de tissus il ya
toi je venais même des bâtonniers
d'escrimé c'était plutôt des des images
que je trouvais dans mon propre pratique
et qui m'appartenaient de toute façon et
qu'ils étaient tous bien de d'époques
différentes ou aussi qui était de 2 pour
une différente intentions et qui que
j'avais abandonné mais qui ceux qui se
retrouvaient réconcilier sur le sur un
tableau et à partir de ce
le principe très simple les choses se
sont très vite
complexifié et et de là est venue
maintenant à la fin jusqu'à présent 10
ans cette série de que j'appelle lieu
dit parce que ce sont des lieux où
quelque chose de très nouveau un milieu
pour moi et cette chose nouvelle c'est
une espèce de pousser interne qui a fait
craquer la surface du tableau et qui qui
l'a poussé hors du temps et hors du
cadre aussi etc ces choses là que je
vais montrer la mer à la galerie lelong
ces camps et c'est le judy prochain avec
les tic sont très désarçonné devant ton
travail parce qu'en général ils ont une
attitude
j'aime j'aime ça sans avoir besoin d'en
d'en rajouter ou de légitimer leur leurs
critiques c'est souvent il ya une
approbation comme ça spontanée en
général j'ai vite pour moi même de ne
pas m'ennuyer mais vu dieu j'ai vite
m'ennuyer et jeu parce que je trouve que
ça c'est absurde de faire
une chose qui est très vivre très
difficile et qui doit porter en elle
formidable joie et un intérêt est
surpris une surprise constante et red si
tu étais pas diane ross picasso tu
penses quoi en ce moment du boom qui
assure l'ars c'est à dire que maintenant
l'art est devenu très spéculatif et
qu'il ya des gens à new york et ailleurs
qui achètent des tableaux sans les voir
sur les tableaux restent au même endroit
on lui sort de temps en temps pour la
presse en fait ils sont enfermés dans
des coffres et ils servent en fait de
uniquement pour des transactions
marchandes tu réagis comme ans devance à
moi j'essaie d'imaginer un poète qui
tout d'un coup en vendant une dans une
vente aux enchères son dernier poème
très très chiant et tout d'un coup on
dirait
tiens il ya un boom extraordinaire sur
la poésie on va demander aux poètes
qu'est ce qu'il en pense et je suis sûr
qu'ils diraient quelque chose de
formidable
briand est sublime et
les tentes ne sont pas aussi sublime ils
sont beaucoup plus matérialiste
donc ils ont une réaction tout à fait
comme tout le monde devant un phénomène
pareil
et moi je dois dire c'est quelque chose
qui me ne me réjouis pas mais qu'ils ne
me cassent pas beaucoup non plus tu
crois que tu te sers de la peinture ou
c'est la peinture qui sert de toit
j'essaie de ne pas trop dominer la
teinture j'ai c'est que d'être très
attentif de d'observer qu'est-ce-qui de
caisse qu'il arrive et de canaliser les
choses qui sont en train de se faire
mais je ne me laisse pas dominer non
plus par la peinture parce que ce serait
chercher des effets en fait la question
traditionnelle
si on devait donner une définition de
toi qu'est ce que tu voudrais que ce
soit ce que j'aimerais bien c'est que
qui a un côté
quand on me parle pas seulement de moi
comme d'un pacte comme d'un de quelqu'un
d'un artisan qui arrive à faire des
des tableaux plus ou moins esthétique
mais qui est une espèce de regard sur le
monde dans lequel il dit qu'il ya une
réflexion sur le monde dans lequel il
vit c'est à dire que qui a une base
éthique aussi dans le matin sur les
corrections de ne rien rater de 1h10
tube abonnez vous y mettez un peu de
bleu